well joining us now former pensions
minister baroness altman hello t thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning lots to talk to you about but i
wonder if we could just start with that
should the prime minister apologize at
the dispatch box given that's where he
um first came up with a slur
my own view is absolutely he should
absolutely he should
um and i remember during my time as
minister that
i
was hauled over the coals
for apologizing for something i said
which i felt
was uh perhaps a little bit uh
misleading or
you know said something that wasn't
quite right
and i was told ministers don't apologize
and i still do not understand
why
if
one has said something that has been
maybe taken the wrong way or caused
offence even if you didn't mean to do
that
you can't just say sorry
you know it's what we teach our children
in the sake of for the sake of family
harmony even if you don't really think
what you said was wrong
when you get to the point where
everything is all stoked up you just
need to say i'm sorry for the sake of
family harmony and we've got a country
here that that is really clearly there
are some uh angers that people are
boiling over there's there's
you know a real
feeling of tension across the country
and if an apology can calm things down
why would you not do that as a leader of
the country
why do you think he won't
i i must admit that i find it really
truly puzzling
because
uh i don't think that he meant uh to
cause the kind of
hatred and vitriol that has been
apparently stoked up by this
and i do understand actually that
uh kitsakir stama was the leader of
of the cps at the time
uh but we all know he was not personally
involved in in the decision
and sakia stamina at the time apologized
and took responsibility
for being the leader of
an office where mistakes were made
i think that's usually what one would
expect
somebody at the top to do
if they believe that people
have felt if you like let down or
done something that
would be helped
by an apology
totally understand i want to have i
trouble you for a couple of thoughts on
pensions first of all mps uh voting
through a pension rise that will be
outstripped by inflation yesterday and
the chancellor's removed the triple lock
thoughts on that
well i was leading a rebellion in the
house of lords and we put a very
reasonable compromise
to the government that would allow
the keeping of the earnings link in the
triple lock it's the earnings protection
that has been abandoned
and has caused so much problem
and unfortunately mps in the commons
voted against that
it would have given a
much fairer increase to both
the state pension and what's called the
pension credit which is the top-up that
the poorest pensioners live on which has
always been increased in line with
earnings and suddenly because
earnings rose very fast during the
pandemic
that the link was dropped i think that
was a terrible decision i would love to
see the government
go back on its
decision but i don't think there's any
chance of that and practically it's
probably too late to change the systems
but pensioners are going to struggle the
poorest pensioners in particular
have been shortchanged they were
promised the protection that has been
taken away
and i just don't agree with that policy
i'm afraid
and i also wondered if you had a thought
on suggestions from labour that a
windfall tax would be the right way
forward for some of these oil companies
in order to try to bring down energy
bills for those that need it most the
flip side to that is the government is
saying that a lot of pension funds um
are invest in things like bp shell et
cetera et cetera et cetera so it could
impact on pensioners in that direction
do you think that's a reasonable
argument
well
i think one can go a little bit too far
on the issue of
worrying about whether or not you should
impose taxation policy because of what's
happening in pension funds but i do
think that
one has to be careful not to
take away the ability of
our biggest energy companies to invest
in clean energy i
i think that the move to net zero is
right i hope the government does not
roll back on that and i don't
see signs yet that the government is
doing that although there is some
pressure trying to encourage that and
there are a lot of companies that have
done extraordinarily well out of both
the pandemic
and the central bank policies of
creating new money which has
inflated asset prices and and shares and
property
so you know there is a case for saying
that if you need to raise large sums in
taxation
one should look to
raise that from a broader base uh which
has benefited
rather than
the national insurance increase which i
fundamentally disagree with
which places uh an extra burden
on the lower earners whose pay packets
will be
falling
of this april at the same time as the
cost of living is soaring so yes i think
there is a case for broadening
the base from which one takes
extra taxation clearly we need
extra public money to
invest and
shore up both the health service and
particularly social care which is still
being left out
but whether or not you should single out
the oil companies who we need i mean we
can see geopolitically
russia is threatening to cut off gas to
the west potentially
and
there is a real problem because of our
dependence
on uh
forms of energy that are not necessarily
controlled in this country and we need
to invest
in environmentally friendly energy
sources the best people to do that are
probably uh some of the bigger energy
companies
so
i don't i just don't think we should
single out one sector in particular okay
baroness altman uh fascinating thank you
so much for taking the time
thank you